now firefighters in greece say they're
doing what is humanly possible to
contain raging wildfires but the
situation on the country's second
largest island evia is still far from
under control locals are being joined by
firefighters from across europe and
elsewhere they're doing what they can to
tame the flat the fires but those
affected by the blazes have begun
criticizing their government saying it
could have done more to stop the
destruction
well let's hear about the situation on
the ground from our correspondents who
are following the fires there dw's
barbara basil is on the greek island of
evia and julia han is on turkey's aegean
coast welcome to you both barbara let's
start with you what's the situation on
the island where you are today
the large part of the north of evia is
burned like this is just one of the
million of pine trees that have been
raised to the ground here and it is a
scene of complete devastation the fires
are not yet completely under control
because the forest floor is so hot
and we have 40 degrees again out here
that any slightest movement of wind or
whatever just a spark jumping reignites
them so the firefighters are still out
there in the interior on the steep hills
of this island and putting out
individual fires and we again we see
helicopters sort of circling around and
trying to figure out the new outbreaks
and extinguish them as quickly as they
can but large parts of this virgin
beautifully beautiful forest are
completely dead and scarred and charred
it looks like a moonscape people have
lost their livelihoods as we have heard
and there is indeed a very sad and a
very angry mood
julia turkey has suffered numerous
wildfires so far you've been covering
them have authorities managed to get
those under control
well two weeks after the first blazes
erupted here in turkey the situation
finally appears to be under control
although firefighting operations
continue in at least one location here
in the province of muller according to
authorities but many are warning that it
is still too early to give the all clear
because the conditions that have fueled
the fires in recent days haven't changed
it's still very hot very dry and very
windy now the wildfires here in turkey
are said to be the worst in decades they
have left so much destruction at least
eight people were killed and tens of
thousands had to leave their homes the
flames have turned huge tracts of
forests and fields into gray landscapes
according to the latest estimates a
total of about 150 000 hectares of land
has been destroyed nationwide an area
roughly two times the size of new york
city just to give you an
image an idea of the extent of the
damage
barbara the greek prime minister has
offered what sounds like an apology he's
promised compensation for those affected
by the fires is the government
acknowledging that it didn't prepare for
this properly
not openly and not really this sort of
halfway apology that we heard the day
before yesterday was just meant to sort
of calm down nerves to tell people i met
your sides but the government had put
out a forest protection plan this on in
june this year and of course nothing so
far nothing at all had been implemented
thousands of new policemen were employed
in greece but the country has only four
thousand firefighters overall for the
whole country and again here we saw
about the same amount of devastation as
in turkey was around 150 000 acres of
forests and fields having been burned so
yes they didn't take the threat
seriously even though it burns here
every summer they totally underestimated
the consequences of climate change and
now they sort of scrabbling to make good
but it's going to take a lot to to get
people back on their side and there is a
tremendous anger here in the villages
people are just furious when you even
mention the government
anger there in turkey well the uh uh in
in greece the turkish president recep
tayyip erdogan yulia uh also made
promises of compensation to the victims
there is the government ready to
introduce tough measures to avoid
situations like this in the future
well the severity and the
destructiveness of the wildfires here in
turkey are putting pressure on president
edwan and his government to act they are
facing fierce criticism over what many
view as a lack of preparedness but also
the calls for more climate action are
growing louder because turkey is
facing increasingly frequent disasters
experts link to climate change not just
forest fires but also droughts flash
floods or the so-called cease not plague
in the sea of marmaras but climate
change hasn't really been a political
priority here in the country turkey
remains one of only six nations that
haven't yet ratified the 2015 paris
agreement on climate change now
president erdogan is not a climate
change denier and his government have
has put forward action plans but experts
say that is simply not enough the
government has to start
taking the causes and effects of global
warming much more seriously
julia thank you very much that was our
correspondent yulia han there reporting
from turkey and on the greek island of
evia dw's barbara basil thank you very
much to you both
well the wildfires tearing along the
mediterranean coast are just some of the
blazes burning around the globe nasa and
the european space agency have released
satellite photos now showing just how
widespread forest fires are right now
fire zones are indicated in red as well
as near record flames in california this
image shows heavy wildfires in south
america and africa you can just make it
out there that also ablaze parts of the
middle east and even northern europe and
asia right up to the arctic circle
so satellites have also picked up
details like smoke trails from the fires
in turkey spreading across the
mediterranean it's a warning from space
the planet is burning faster than many
of us realize
well joining me now to talk about the
science behind these fires is dr clement
abergeel
he's from climate application he's
climate application scientist from the
european space agency dr abigail thank
you very much for being with us what
sort of message should governments be
getting from the evidence that you and
your colleagues are delivering about
extreme weather events and climate
change
well thank you very much
the ipcc has released earlier this week
on monday the key finding of the working
group one contribution to the sixth
assessment report of the physical
science basis of climate change what we
have learned is that climate change is
happening here and now and linked to
human activities are our conception of
fossil fuels as you said satellites such
as those operated by the european space
agency in partnership with the european
commission and under the copenhagues
program permit to monitor different fire
characteristics
and this fits the ict
evaluation and explain our changing
climate the reports provide estimates of
the chances of crossing the global
warming level of 1.5 degrees in the next
decades and find that unless there are
immediate rapid and logical reduction in
greenhouse gas emission limiting warming
to close to 1.5 degree or even 2 degrees
will be beyond reach moving forward
those efforts to combat climate change
and to deal with these extreme events we
need a rapid and large scale reduction
in carbon dioxide emission and other
greenhouse gas emissions and reach
carbon naturality as early as possible
right now you study moisture in the soil
and vegetation i understand
we're looking at many fires right now
burning what have you learned
that can help us prevent the kinds of
wildfires that we're seeing right now
that's right with all those satellite
data we can monitor different fire
characteristics areas that are dry and
prone to wildfire outbreak actively
flaming and smoldering fires burned area
as well as smoke and trace gas emission
we can learn from this vast amount of
data we have collected over the year and
the first step is to acknowledge
the risk under warming climate extreme
events such as prolonged heat wave and
drought are going to increase both in
engine intensity and frequency this is a
proven fact and perhaps we need to
address regulations on homes built in
fire prone areas we can also use
prescribed fire in period of the year
where the risk of fire is lower to cool
away excess vegetation that can fuel
runaway blazes in forest and grassland
during a summer during higher risk area
and we also need to rise awareness of
this higher risk of wildfire outbreak in
our changing world
now you mentioned in your in your first
answer there about the ipcc report on on
global warming it's now you know that
humans are making this happen is
considered not indisputable as a fact
you said that changes need to be made
and co2 emissions rapid reductions deep
reductions do you think that will happen
uh in time to prevent the sort of
tipping point that you've described
i think we definitely need to go towards
that we need to implement those
decarbonization strategies in line with
the paris agreement on climate and
you've mentioned it through real
business changes and innovations
including efficiency improvement
renewable energy coming back to the ipcc
many of the changes observed in the
climate are unprecedented and some of
the changes already set in motion such
as continued sea level rise are
irreversible over hundreds of thousands
of years however
true and sustained reduction in emission
of carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gas would limit climate change while
some benefits from example for air
quality will come rather quickly it
could take up to 20 years to see global
average temperatures stabilized
so mitigation and adaptation dr clement
eberg of
abigail rather from the european space
agency thank you very much for being
with us today on dw news
we're in a burned forest a few
kilometers outside of athens and with me
is costa from the world wildlife fund
what are we seeing here actually this
tree is still burning even though the
flames have been largely extinguished
you are seeing a tree burning and then
on the side on the background you'll see
you know a lot of smoke coming out from
the roots the roots and the trees will
be burning for four weeks actually
so it takes constant monitoring and
the fire brigade will be intervening all
the time to to take this fire down now
the prime minister has said he would
replant all these forests this is 150
000 acres of forests around essence that
have been burned here
is that even possible or is that an
empty promise this is what we always
hear uh but most of the forests will not
really need replanting actually because
you know this is the mediterranean
forests are
adapted to fire so
most of it will be regenerated naturally
uh as long as we make sure it does not
go away so if you have if we start
having houses popping out
or you know farming popping out or
things like that we've seen all around
the greece and this is one of the
reasons we have a lot of oceans all
around the med actually not only in
greece uh then we will lose the forest
if we protect the forest and keep it
nature will do it it will gradually do
its job but it takes a long time but it
will take a long time it will take this
is a pine forest so it will take a good
15 to 20 years before it's back in that
in that shape again so essence has
really lost a lot by losing this forest
because this morning was the green lung
of the greek capital wasn't it yes this
was the green land that remained
uh athens used to have in the past
decades quite a lot of forests around it
but we've gradually lost it from
pentelian himatus and a large fire in
parnitha about 15 years ago so yeah this
is this is one of the remaining lines
we're losing today what can be done for
prevention we watched the fire fighting
efforts they seemed haphazard as at best
if to put it mildly so really what needs
to be done i mean the fires need to be
prevented not not only foreign
when you need to extinguish a fire it's
already too late
fires need to be prevented and not
extinguished uh and what we see in
greece and what we see in all the
mediterranean countries during the past
decades is a loss of knowledge
and loss of interest in prevention
prevention is a very scientific
approach it does not show off so
politicians don't get the credit for it
and it you usually don't see it because
if it's good then you don't see the
results because you don't see the fires
so people are not investing in
prevention uh they rather invest in
planes or they rather invest in in fancy
uh truck
fire machines uh
all of these are useful but all of these
are you know additional to prevention
because what we see is that once a fire
reaches a certain size and uh especially
under climate change and with the
temperatures we're having and with the
winds we're having
then it's almost impossible to
extinguish and you know
200 kilometers north from here in evia
we're getting a huge fire that we cannot
control exactly for that reason so
prevention is the key
and most of the investment
the countries greece the countries that
made the european union is doing for
forest protection should go in the
prevention side
castle thank you very much you're very
welcome thank you
meanwhile algeria's president said
dozens of soldiers died saving residents
from wildfires in that country's
forested
region state tv says at least 65 people
have been killed in the blazes so far
scorching temperatures and severe water
shortages have made it difficult for
crews to fight the fires officials say
arsonists may be to blame three days of
national mourning have been declared
you